AA
OME IC
L IF THAT'S E.T IT IS
ST T GREAT" CARLSON ANOX AREOON
SEEMS
R
INA  FOXNEG I-BIDEN,N E R.T TH
WH
T  THIS.
SO MATTH CHANC
>> Transla TD
SI
M ALLF  AGAIN HSSIA'S
THREAT AGAINST UKRAINE,
WANTS TOIGHLIGHTES NOT WT BEIUSR
E TO JHALD FEEL IF XICO ANDLLIT
>> AND THAT'S INCIALT
KREMLINO
SURPRI,  GUESTS
AGREE.>> Trala
THIS A.
SARITY OF
THISU. NPOS RUILDU
>> ReporT RUSSIA
ROVERSL  INCLUDITHSISELF, D OFT.
LIUMNG THE SOF OVER E ESB
RUSSIA MED THE
ELSS, TRUMP IRST
>>TIE
JUST SAID IT'S NOT RUSSIA.I LLH
T. PR
LESSOPHIBIISIDHING WCAN
CRITICS HELDP SE.
AS JUSTIFIEACTIOMARRTD LINEDIV,
E SITUATION AS  COMPARED TO EOPI
DANGELYWAF USILONTH LEAVINGAN
JUSTOW U.S.
MAHET INONORE WITH JULIA
FFS WRITINT K. FOX NEWS, NEWSMA.
WHEN AMERICAN RIGH BOUT A DECADG
ZAON  WMUNIST
FAMILIESAND
WING D WITH THEM AN
T FE
PUTIN AS AAS A
ASOMUL
NSHIP WI, OU
E SHOULDN'IZE.
AND WHAT H DEVELOPED ITHLAST FIS
YOU EITHER HAVE THTTING
TH
SOCIAL MEDIA AMPLIFYAT
MESSAGE.UNTIL IT, YOKNOWS REOR
DIINOUT
TR STORY
AND NOW E BASICALLY ONEDCKE,L A,
THE MAIN STATE BROADCASTERCO ONV
THE BLACK S RO J, RACIAL JUSTIC
SAME  BEINGARELY ITBEING FULLY
NOHAVE STATE
EC RT TS, THAT THEY'RE
RADICALS, ABOUT TOAKE THOV ONEST